yeah well you did this movie in 2020
Pearl yes that looked like it was it was
a difficult role was it not Pearl was my
first little independent movie yeah my
first lead role Anthony Le peglia yes
and it also had somebody else in them no
one who was the friend of mine she was
on the podcast she was fantastic yeah
she is incredible what's so wild is I
like
Bobby Roth the director like told me a
little bit about her and then when she
got there I I also like to like come
into things and I really not know so
much about people because it almost like
brings like this intimidation on you
know so I I was happy that I didn't
really like I knew she had been in a
couple things and she was just so kind
and just so humble that I was like then
after like reading like watched a bunch
of her work and I was like she's good
she is angry she's been incredible so
many things yes yeah she's great and
Anthony Paglia yeah was he cool amazing
can you still talk to him yes but he was
the I think I'm like so grateful that
being my
uh my first you know bigger role in a
film being with him was just what he
taught me and I know there was I
remember there was this one day where it
was a pretty emotional scene and I was
like putting so much pressure on myself
of like it has to be per here the whole
Perfection thing it has to be perfect
like I want to do great I want to give
my all like this is like the first take
and I'm just putting so much added
pressure on myself so we do this the
take the first take and
he comes down he pulls me aside he's
like you are putting way too much
pressure on yourself
holy crap he's like shake that off good
for him and I was like he's like Larson
you're like coming into this wanting to
start sobbing crying that is not what
you like you wouldn't just come up to me
like you're like at a birthday party
around a ton of people it wouldn't you
as your own person wouldn't just come up
like sobbing crying like it would just
be over time something that develops and
most the time you're trying not to cry
that's the key so why are you trying to
come into this ball and crying he's like
quit it that is genius yes because
I've this helped me early on yeah
someone said
human beings
we don't want to cry yeah we do
everything not to cry yes so as an actor
you have to think I'm supposed to cry in
this scene and you're like I don't want
to do this I don't want to do this blah
blah and it's just and it's and it comes
out yeah and you're like [__] I don't
want this to and so that's if you play
with that totally that was the answer
wasn't it yes and literally I remember
that the next take I just came into it
being like don't cry like don't like
yourself and I it was like I felt so
great about I just like came out like
hugged him after were you like going
love pagley I love Paglia
no seriously but I'm just really I'm
really grateful for him and what he
taught me through those three months and
just like leading me and knowing it was
like my first
thing and just like it was really a
really great experience I have never met
him but I love him yeah regardless gosh
he's an incredible person so it was it
was a really good first experience
because that could have been tough yeah
you could have been working I'm glad you
didn't work
with an insecure actor yeah whose ego
and the people are weird about things oh
she's prettier than I am or she's this I
have to be I'm gonna be a [__] I'm
gonna be really that could really affect
you especially early on the fact that
you had two supportive people there have
your back a good environment you're
lucky yeah you're very lucky and I'm
happy that it was a good experience yeah
because it's not always that I don't
know how many actors how many actors
I've worked with not not a ton but
people who you go oh man I just thought
they were
I was hoping they'd be cool they're not
cool
um It's usually the really big stars who
are cool
and the people who want to be famous who
are like right there like think they
have something to prove yeah so usually
those guys